welcome to this video playing Kahlan
with black and Turkish FM I get let's
see the bogo yeah the booga-booga-booga
play with d6 as well somewhere under
eight and sideline okay you three that's
not very that's not very aggressive but
definitely playable let's um get e5
prepared hmm yeah you're not going to
prevent it all together that's not going
to happen yeah I can also play this make
sure to get the bishop pair back um
start with this oh yeah maybe take and
then your five it's probably probably
the most flexible way to do it keeping
the the knight on c6 um not yet
committed oh wow it's still probably
this is this is the right place getting
some sort of pressure on deform yeah
that's what they normally do ok so I'm
going to take a little bit on the
queenside ok
just just keep this position the night
on d8 looks weird but I can't play yeah
I can't play Barry of things I can play
with f5 night to f7 or I can do the
following which gets my night to see
Five ultimately yeah I think c6 was more
interesting actually unless I'm
blundering something here because now i
get to see 5 which is quite nice after
see 695 at least he has the space
advantage of the pawns which is not
happening here here just have this this
nice nice night the nice night outpost
um yeah look a 344 awkward pin maybe
yeah that's slightly awkward for him
let's see how he handles it and there
are some tricks like Quincy to I have
Bishop f5 as a neat neat little trick
Queen takes f5 rook takes be three LED
leads to a night against bishop scenario
which is rather ok for black I'm going
to do that I don't see a drawback
otherwise I'll winner tempo or let me
check is there something better
not really maybe wisest our kel three
queen bee to i have night a for I could
be interesting night a for Queen a
three-night c3 attacking d5 and he to
all of a sudden getting some tactics
going Oh is retreating interesting so
here's some again going into the pen
okay if I go rook could be eight isn't
this getting rather annoying how are you
unpinning after that huh how are you
unpinning now
that's weird isn't this just dropping an
exchange a rock chick c5 maybe and then
d6 stuff like that yeah maybe maybe you
can play that nope does not want to play
that I'm be our night a4 I mean this
looks night f1 isn't this like tying
wide down totally if could not be too
coming that's what a funny position the
rook can only go to see one and then I
have night be 20 can you play a
counter-attack here on my my rook I can
Quincy one yeah this is this kind of
thing okay
take on c3 or is there something better
if I go look a to look a to how are how
are you saving your rook rook a to on a
night move i take c 3 that's really
really funny yeah i can take here I
guess knight c6 got 96 ok I take your
first bishop a 292 is simple knight c6
maybe 96 oh yeah 96's may be possible or
what's my reply I mean the queen is
hanging with check so so I have to move
it I guess yeah I have to move my queen
now but where exactly his next move is
Queen takes you three or night takes
here I left the stance of stuff hanging
Wow
maybe the check here in quincy seven now
with this still the background made
timeline is not working poor okay come
on Queen B seven I need to play a move
it's really weird that I'm not like
immediately winning oh me oh I'm just
start seeing it I mean ok looks it too
we are to keep keep this rock and maybe
that's actually enough yeah maybe that's
enough where's the Queen going
yeah I cheek I just take the snow check
yeah I want to keep this pawn really
it's got a counter maid threat rook see
one but I can play rook c2 it's very
important yeah I don't like to do that
but he cannot go on the seventh because
of back ring made and now i have g6
pushing him back
now Ruby 6 check stupid Haruki 6 was was
also possible check and was possible
probably stronger check ya got dem young
the time ah no stupid is that rookie 6
yeah yeah and check and all of a sudden
this bloody night is it's getting so
active just doing everything to screw it
up reading everything but I only have
one second yeah watch everything fits on
time ah got 37 seconds left in this
totally winning position and there's
still managed to screw this up yeah
that's not easy it's really not easy
it's just an exchange down after being
totally outclassed I mean you get AB
simply added yet it's just the truth
yeah it's very easy you just need to
protect this pawn now and nothing's ever
going to happen here I mean okay this is
also a complete win but the problem was
that here I was just just blundering
basically the pump the pawn on e5 I just
need to be a little bit a bit precise
yeah like it it's a h5 preventing any
any Knight g4 stuff and then reroute the
rook back and win with the exchanger the
problem was that that i blundered the
porn check would have played rookie 6
with justice better but a shape like
this and here yeah is got h4 h5
yeah that's it's already I mean gasps
still a win but I made life hard at some
yea i meant if it's Janet still a
complete win rook a a young rook e8 look
I tore up t to whatever yeah it's
useless to analyze I'm just screwing up
those totally winning position all the
time and of course it was some it was
probably a much easier win around here
where he totally misplaced all this
stuff but yeah I mean when does the win
is a win what what else do I want to let
us some yeah this yeah rook takes his
six is also good but check of course
this is totally enough here yeah I can I
can play this actually trapping the
night yeah I didn't see that but ok this
is definitely and totally enough oops
rook cb2 is also stronger yeah it's gets
it gets too annoying to look at all the
Sun this again and again um okay if we
start just with the interesting part
around here it is just equal but he
played it a number of very weird moves
this is the first one getting into the
pin which is not a big problem he went
here Bishop f5 yeah queen d 1 is of
course just a joke I mean why this after
the rupee eight now Black is just
winning look take c5 is the better
defense and this is just just downright
losing yeah he's totally misplaced all
his pieces yeah
check yeah handy edge and just an
exchange up ah ok yeah I really
shouldn't play that early in the morning
I should really shouldn't but I keep
trying ok thanks for watching